all right let's check in with liquor
lineup the sponsors of this segment we
heard the bad elves are having a
Kamikaze Christmas and here's the drink
that will keep them going
Welcome to our shop my name is Solomon
I'm here with Mo what is our liquor
lineup for today today we're making a
raspberry Kamikaze something you can
enjoy right after your Christmas dinner
so first of all we have two ounces of
vodka
two ounces of Chambord
and then our TA we find a lot off with
two ounces of Cointreau just for the
sweetness
all of these ingredients can be found on
our app download our app liquor lineup
on the App Store and we deliver daily
shake the cocktail just slightly
and then just string straight
wow that looks phenomenal and it's good
idea about it oh it's gonna be very
strong and finally we garnish it with a
little bit of raspberries
enjoy
[Music]
that keeps the Christmas spirit going oh
it's gonna be good
thank you liquor lineup for sponsoring
this segment give them a call at
702-616-0311 for more information you
can also scan that QR code right there
on your screen